hi there reject nation greg and john
here today
so
uh
wow i i can't believe this day has come
i wanted to do this quick little video
and just sort of talk from the heart
there's some things i really do want to
uh express today uh because yeah we're
we're we're going to the premiere of
spiderman no way home it almost it
doesn't feel real it was so last minute
and uh now we're apparently going and i
want to thank you guys for
watching us for for however long you've
been here because i know without all of
you watching sort of amount of coverage
you've done over this one movie over the
past year or even longer
we wouldn't have such a such a great
opportunity i almost didn't go uh i i
was invited but then i wasn't able to
didn't look like john would be able to
come
and because john didn't want to you know
i'll wait till january with the rest of
the world he wasn't even wasn't able to
get a pass and then it came to a moment
where we look like we can get him a pass
so it was like all right let's do it
let's go
and
now here we are so
we're going to be doing like one of
those instant reactions and honest
thoughts review which is never
nerve-wracking
because you got to get all your your
thoughts properly formatted and i'll be
honest if i end up not liking it you by
this point you guys should know that
if
premieres don't phase me as much even if
something like this won't faze me i'll
i'll be honest and let you guys know if
i end up enjoying it or not and i also
clarify we won't do any spoilers and in
fact it's gonna be a really hard one to
talk about because
i'm thinking about like if i say this
movie gave me everything i wanted i feel
like that's a spoiler
yeah slightest hint of anything would be
a spoiler so it's going to be a
fascinating process to review it's going
to be interesting because you're going
to be very careful with having to talk
on the fly about this movie outside of
coming out of a premiere which i'm sure
will generate a lot of very exciting
feelings and especially because um just
did a re-watch of all the spider-man
movies and i do want to do a ranking
video
because
i find it very i was talking about this
on twitter recently
my opinion and ranking of the films
has drastically changed like so much so
that i was surprised by oh my god i
actually think this might be my favorite
spider-man and this this movie actually
climbed way higher and this one went
down a lot i was pretty surprised by on
the re-watch
so neither so i i'm especially i'll
especially be honest because um far from
home is actually at the bottom of my
list and towards the bottom not the very
bottom
but it's towards the bottom of the list
so going into the very next installment
it's going to be an interesting
experience
but
what i really wanted to talk about is
because you guys know how excited we are
for this and a lot of you guys are
excited this is like the talk of the
town talk of the world this movie
it's almost on our end feeling like a
bittersweet ending like i've talked with
paul from heavy spoilers about this i've
talked with uh warren because of wonder
extensively about this we've talked a
lot about it behind the scenes this
journey of spider-man no way home has
been something insanely unique
for i'm sure all of us but especially
for us youtubers because you know this
started off with just leaks rumors
speculation theories and that's pretty
much all it's been up until a couple
months ago we started getting like
photos footage
and
now here we are
and i've never this channel in
particular has never been part of such a
journey it's like i remember when we had
to say bye to wandavision that was just
a few weeks and that right there was we
were saying bye to the actual product
here we were we're saying bye to
this journey of anticipation yeah and
it's been such a weird wild ride and
some people don't know this i've
expressed this to a few people of how
everyone every once in a while john and
i will shoot videos uh that
we'll film it and then we might film
like 10 to 20 minutes and then by the
end of it we're like i don't like that
let's not put it up or sometimes i
review the footage like let's not put it
up and there's only been like two or
three spider-man videos that we were
like yeah i don't like doing that let's
not put it up yeah so most of it
has been this crazy yeah katamari of
anticipation and theorizing and and yeah
it's been it's literally been
captivating us all year
ah so yeah it's kind of a weird thing
because you know once this movie comes
out of course we're going to talk about
it we'll probably talk about it for a
little while afterwards too i'm sure
it's going to generate a lot of
theories and whatnot we'll probably have
a spoiler talk um probably a live stream
maybe by monday since i know tickets are
really hard to get i'd rather
about maybe sunday or monday we'll keep
you guys updated on what it'll be
uh but
yeah you know i'm almost
really not ready to let go of the
anticipation feeling because i know that
once we watch like oh
the journey is now coming to a close of
this film but at the same time you guys
it's like we all we want to watch the
other day we want to watch it like it's
like you can't just live in anticipation
you gotta watch the film yeah yeah one
with the amount of time changing so much
between uh originally we thought we
weren't gonna be able to see it until
opening night thursday and i mean it's
sort of been where my heart has has
remained at so it's taken me a while to
convince myself like no no no it's
tonight like this will the spell will
break and we will see what the secrets
were tonight and i'm not prepared yeah
because we've as many leaks as we've
covered
there's also been a lot of leaks that we
were like
that's definitely not true or i'm not
sure if i believe that and i've also
talked about this quite a lot with other
people
is i have no idea any clue how this
movie's ultimately going to end i have
no clue how it's going to end like at
that moment when dr strange is like
they're breaking through i can't stop
them in the official trailer
no clue what they're talking about at
that moment i have no idea what's going
to become of that
uh
everything is theories and even even
when it comes to speculation and leaks
that we've seen it's all about execution
at the end of the day you know you could
hear
plot elements or plot twists or whatever
but it's all about how the execution
ultimately unfolds so it's still going
to be fresh it's still going to be new
it's still going to be exciting it's
going to be a journey it's going to be
fun to see what does come true what
doesn't come true and also
mine and a lot of other people's
reputations are on the line right now
because there's some things that we all
want to be in this movie and if it's not
in here it's like this this is not
looking that's not good
yeah everyone who was so sure that
certain things are gonna happen now is
the moment of truth where we we gotta
put our money where our mouths are it's
gonna be a spider-man meme of a bunch of
youtubers pointing at each other going i
would believe this because of you
you reported on this version i'll never
trust a video of yours again
that's what it's all gonna come down to
yeah uh but guys this has been a hell of
a journey so yeah if there's anything
like tv spots or something that comes
out now after we watch it there's no
point in us covering it and to me that's
a big part of the fun of this is is the
speculation and covering like the the
little clips here and there like i love
that feeling i really do love it you
know it's it's something that
it's exciting we look we look forward to
it every single time we're such big fans
of spider-man and of this franchise
because as much as i wanted there's only
one spider-man movie out of my whole
re-watch that i was like i don't think i
like this one yeah the other ones it's
like i have a ranking too yeah that's
the one i have a ranking
but i also like all them there's just
one that i'm really unsure if i actually
like it or not that's been a nice thing
about revisiting these films is you
realize what a privilege it is to have
so many spider-man films to watch and
talk about and how even if some of them
lack or or aren't as good as others
they're all for the most part really fun
and imaginative yeah you know and i've
seen the spectacular spider-man show and
this year of course in the 90s
spider-man cartoon so it's like i've
seen so much it's been so much
spider-man that to finally be at this
moment
where we're getting the spider-man end
game film yeah one and two for the
culmination of like i'll never forget
seeing that first spider-man movie in
the theaters and i feel like we were the
right age to really live with and grow
up with the entire spider-man friend
it's like the batman movies we had those
growing up but those are a little bit
before or they started a little bit
before our time and i feel like
spider-man you know it truly has that
special place for at least for me and my
heart i'm like yeah i've grown up with
this character and watched so many
iterations of the movies and i never
ever would have expected to see them
potentially collide like they are now
and i know that we are extremely
privileged right now we are very gifted
uh to be in this position to be able to
go to the premiere and we do not take
that for granted so thank you guys so
much for this amazing journey it's only
going to keep on going there's there
will be more spider-man vids this week
and probably the next because i'm sure
this was going to break open some doors
here
but thank you guys and keep a look out
for our we might do like a quick
reaction and then we'll do uh you know
like a full on
uh a little review outside of the
theater uh right when it's done and
probably up tomorrow morning
much love flip flip reject nation see
you soon
[Music]
you